there's a misinformed market about this
and I'd have to disclose you know I run
on building indexes with footsie Russell
I'm gonna disclose something today I won
the CNBC stocktaking contest yesterday
we've got that picture of that thing
here somewhere but here's how I did it I
simply went back to an index called all
USA that footsie Russell built when it
was time to call those stocks and asked
them what were the two heaviest weighted
names in that index at that time it was
Boeing and Apple they beat everybody all
the active stock pickers got cleaned out
by this actively managed index which is
basically the mind of a very strong
manager instituted into rules that they
built this is a new form of investing at
half the price I used to pay Lowe's
managers 100 basis points I pay him 48
now and I whacked all those guys I'm
using these indexes what people don't
understand is they're taking over
they're not robots they're they're
researchers and they tell you they build
what you want is that basically what's
happening yeah that's exactly what's
happening Kevin and congratulations by
the way on being the winner of the stock
thank you I love to gloat but I don't
really dad yesterday it markers down
4.1% Oh USA Index managed by footsie
Russell was down 3.6 that's 40 basis
points out performance it's it's it's
people doing the research beating the
old stock picker guys that's my point
and so that's essentially an actively
managed strategy before you invest in
osho's investment funds please refer to
the prospectus for important information
about the investment objectives risks
charges and expenses to obtain your
prospectus continuing this and other
important information please visit
www.sap.com/learnbi for you invest there
are risks involved with investing
including the possible loss of principal
concentration in a particular industry
or sector will subject the funds to loss
due to adverse occurrences that may
affect that industry or sector the funds
may use derivatives which may involve
risk different from or greater than
those associated with more traditional
investments the funds emphasis on
dividend paying stocks involves the risk
that
stocks may fall out of favor with
investors and underperform the market
also a company may reduce or eliminate
its dividend after the funds purchase of
such a company's securities returns on
investments in foreign securities it
could be more volatile than or trailer
returns on investments in US securities
exposures to foreign securities entail
special risks including political
diplomatic economic foreign market and
trading risk in addition unless
perfectly hedged the funds investment in
securities denominated in other
currencies could decline due to changes
in local currency relative to the value
of the US dollar which may affect the
funds returns the funds hedging
strategies may not be successful and if
they are successful the funds exposure
to foreign currency fluctuations is not
expected to be fully hedged at all times
see the prospectus for specific risks
regarding the fund past performance does
not guarantee future results shares are
bought and sold at market prices not nav
are not individually redeemable and
owners of the shares may acquire those
shares from the funds and tender those
shares for redemption to the funds in
creation unit aggregations only
consistent 50,000 shares brokerage
commissions will reduce returns though
shares investments funds are distributed
by four side fund services LLC four side
fund Services LLC is not affiliated with
oh she shares investments or any of its
affiliates
you